comme la souligner le président Jean-Luc
glaise les départements répondent à
notre besoin de solidarité de proximité
et de lien social
alors j'en suis convaincu l'avenir de
notre pays passe par les départements
il y a quelques semaines j'avais eu
l'occasion de rencontrer certains
d'entre vous à Matignon
vous m'aviez alors formulé une demande
celle de mettre nos forces en commun
pour répondre aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
ma réponse celle de mon gouvernement est
évidemment oui
aujourd'hui à Agen je souhaite vous
montrer que nous saisirons pleinement la
main tendue et ensemble je veux que nous
passions aux actes
[Musique]